pas besoin d'y rajouter un autocollant
vu à la télé le dernier livre de yann
moix a obligatoirement sa place en
vitrines des librairies orléanaise pour
être sûr de ne pas rater une vente ici
il est même disponible sur 3 présentoirs
différents le premier jour où il est
sorti on l'a me vois que vous voyez là
dans le top des meilleures ventes parce
que il s'est très très bien vendu dès
hier les gens venaient exact
enfin pour ce titre là on a relancé une
commande dès le premier jour parce que
parce qu'on a vu qu'il y avait un
véritable engouement pour ce titre
et c'est vrai que les autres types de la
rentrée littéraire pas s'incline 1
persie à côté par rapport à celui ci 80
exemplaires en stock 30 vendus en une
seule journée dans cette librairie
les chiffres sont comparables aux ventes
des derniers michel houellebecq ou
amélie nothomb aux temps modernes une
enseigne moins grand public et plus
spécialisée en littérature on réserve
aussi un accueil particulier à orly
j'ai l'impression que les mets mes
confrères en france n'ont pas
particulièrement soutenu le livre en ce
qui concerne les librairies orléanaise
ici comme ailleurs bien évidemment on en
a pris un petit peu plus pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée les livres
précédents de yann moix
on en avait pris très modestement ici
aux temps modernes un exemplaire là
celui ci je crois que nous en avons pris
12 2 exemplaires d'orléans étaient
vendus ici le premier jour auxquels il
faut ajouter 7 nouvelles lectrices qui a
découvert l'auteur à la télé vous
achetez vos coups durs habituellement
non pas du tout du tout du tout c'est
parce que je vous dis j'ai vu faire
partager voilà pourquoi je cherchais une
librairie cgem pas souvent sur orléans
et je regardais librairie ce que je
prends pas de tram pour aller voir le
médecin légiste ya une librairie pas
tout de suite voilà en attendant de
connaître son destin littéraire orléans
a déjà le mérite comme d'autres livres
d'auteurs médiatique d'attirer un
nouveau public dans les librairies